the Department of Health and Human
Services is pushing back against a New
York Times report that the Trump
administration tried to block a UN
effort to promote breastfeeding The
Times reported that the u.s. wanted to
remove language that called on
governments to protect promote and
support breastfeeding global health
experts told the Times breast milk is
especially important in poor countries
or clean water to mix with powdered
formula may be hard to come by in a
statement to CBS News HHS said quote
women should have the choice and access
to alternatives for the health of their
babies and a new study in JAMA
Pediatrics found that babies who are
breastfed get better sleep when solid
food is added to their diet it also
found babies who started on solid foods
at four months old slept nearly 17
minutes longer per night at the
six-month mark our doctor Tara Narula is
here with more so a lot to go through
Tara yes the first and foremost and I
can't believe we're even talking about
this can you once again remind our
viewers why breastfeeding is so
crucially important those first few
months of life beyond a breastfeeding is
considered the gold standard of
nutrition based on the fact that it has
special nutrients it has hormones
antibodies enzymes live cells and so
that is why the American Academy of
Pediatrics and others recommend that
infants be exclusively breastfed until
six months and then to go on to continue
breastfeeding up to one year with at
that point the addition of foods when
you look at the benefits to infants
infants who have been breastfed have
less asthma less ear and respiratory
infections less SIDS less obesity and
less rates of diabetes in addition when
you look at the benefits to the moms
there's decreased risk of postpartum
hemorrhage menstrual breeding earlier
return to pre-pregnancy weight and
decreased risk of ovarian and breast
cancer so a lot of benefits there on
both sides we've known about many of
these benefits to breastfeeding and now
this controversy that's gone on why
would the Trump administration try and
block this international resolution that
would promote breastfeeding well I think
Norah I mean that's a question of
politics and it depends on how you
interpret what's going on but I think
the reality is there's no argument that
breastfeeding is rarely as I said the
nutritional gold standard now there are
women who
not breastfeed and women who choose not
to breastfeed and in that case formula
is a safe and healthy alternative option
it's been around since the 1920s it's
evolved over time to try to meet the
composition and performance of breast
milk it's never going to meet it exactly
because it doesn't have the antibodies
but it does people who make formula the
manufacturers have to meet nutrient
requirements set by the FDA and they all
have sort of similar compositions of
protein carbohydrates vitamins minerals
water and fat and we should note the
administration didn't just try to stop
this from happening they threatened
other countries that were supporting it
according to the New York Times
reporting let me ask you about a new
JAMA Pediatrics study which suggests
adding solid foods it can help a baby
sleep how should parents navigate that
new information you've all been in this
and wondering yes LR yes should I add
rice cereal or oatmeal early so that my
baby can sleep are they hungry is that
why they're waking up and there's really
not been a lot of guidance I mean as I
mentioned the recommendation is to
really exclusively breastfeed to six
months but some pediatricians will
recommend solids at starting at four
months in this study they looked at
about thirteen hundred infants starting
at three months and they basically
divided them into two groups one that
was exclusively breastfed till six
months and one were they started solids
as early as 16 weeks and though that
group that they started solids in did
sleep on average longer about two hours
per week woke up less about two times
less per week improved quality of life
for moms so it may be beneficial for
sleep all around come health it was
important I'm helped with my
two-year-old